سنبدأ هذه الساعة
بالأخبار العاجلة لأنه منذ دقائق
حصلنا للتو على مقطع فيديو مثير جديد من
البنتاغون أصدره الجيش حيث
يمكنك رؤية طائرة مقاتلة روسية وهي
تقترب من الجزء الخلفي
للطائرة الأمريكية بدون طيار التي تم إسقاطها الآن  لحوالي
أربعة إلى خمسة آلاف قدم في
البحر الأسود، في هذا الفيديو الذي تم
إصداره للتو منذ لحظات، يمكنك أن ترى أين
تتجه الطائرة المقاتلة الروسية
إلى هذه الطائرة الأمريكية بدون طيار، وهي تصب
الوقود عليها، وهذا ما ترونه  في
الفيديو وهي تقترب من هنا،
ثم تبتعد الطائرة وتعود
وتتخلص من المزيد من الوقود ثم تصطدم
بالطائرة الأمريكية بدون طيار، وتقطع الطائرة بدون طيار ما فعلته إحدى
الطائرات المقاتلة الروسية، وذلك
عندما ترى الأشرطة الملونة هناك في
النهاية بالطبع هذا  هو ما أدى
إلى إسقاط هذه الطائرة بدون طيار التي كنا
نتابعها طوال الأسبوع منذ حدوث ذلك.
هذا التفاعل الذي حدث يوم
الثلاثاء قيل لنا أنه استمر لأكثر من
نصف ساعة الآن بالطبع أنه
تم إسقاط الطائرة الأمريكية بدون طيار في
البحر الأسود.  ميلي، رئيس هيئة
الأركان المشتركة، يقول إنه على عمق
حوالي أربعة إلى خمسة آلاف قدم تحت
الماء، يحاول الروس
استعادته الآن وسط
تساؤلات حول ما يمكن أن يستخلصوه
منه إذا فعلوا ذلك.